yeah the backlash to all of this was
pretty broad uh Lea and big and
therefore Ikea stalman's allies I'm sure
would argue he has acted swiftly in
withdrawing uh the labor whip from uh
Diane Abbott he said when he became
labor leader uh that he would have a
zero tolerance approach to racism and
anti-Semitism and a labor spokesperson
has said in the last hour this the labor
party completely condemned these
comments which are deeply offensive and
wrong the chief whip has suspended the
labor whip from Diane Abbott pending an
investigation she's now the 16th
independent MP within Parliament joining
her close uh Ally on the left of the
party and indeed her a former partner
Jeremy corbyn he of course was suspended
not dissimilar a circumstances one
question someone may be posing is what
happens next to Diane Abbott there could
be detractors within the labor party who
want her to follow similar path to Mr
Corbin kirst armor making it clear in
recent weeks that Jeremy corbyn will not
stand as a labor candidate at the next
election of course Diane Abbott has been
a bit of a Trailblazer in Parliament the
first black woman MP she's been there 36
years now 69 years old so may uh feel
that she wants to retire at the next
election she certainly has a memoir out
next year but I think it's certainly
possible that people use these very
controversial comments are widely
condemned by senior figures in both the
conservative note parties to you know
bring an end to her career within uh
Palm would like to hear from both
cabinet ministers and even possibly
Shadow cabinet ministers in the coming
hours because Lee I think it's very
clear the
um response to this the backlash has
been strong and a lot of people want to
make their views clear